ich hab mit dem kettcar durch mit der es
mit paar leute ich bin wieder fc flock
tempel verbrechen hat willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute liebe leute
machen was das für sehr lange nicht mehr
gemacht haben und zwar häufiger etwas
anderes leute ja nicht wehren macht er
nicht abgeht das ist doch mega ausgelöst
ich kann auch verstehen wenn leute sagen
lass mal das break in ruhe lasst mal
leon in ruhe und wie man sie sagen
würden apotheke und marschieren
eindeutig in diese richtung youtube
beginne die andere richtung aber auch
eine sehr schöne richtung und zwar wir
uns heute ein video ein von bibi
produktpalette aber aus einer zeit
mobilfunk fast noch nicht babys produkt
callas war sondern baby
damals waren die produkte nicht so
präsent mittlerweile ist das mit dem
produkt natürlich bisschen anders wie
das wissen ja alle damit noch gar nicht
reden ein bisschen wie die gehört
einfach süddeutschland dazu ja genau wie
lehrern oder geht man kann über die
nützlich machen ist doch witzig aber sie
gehört dazu die sind so wenige richtig
welche andere schräge und auch nervige
typen eurer klasse den er am anfang
überhaupt nicht gemocht hat aber mit der
zeit habe ich einfach den gewöhnt und
findet auch ein paar schöne sachen daran
dass existiert aber wie gesagt wir
machen heute eine zeitreise und zwar
reisen wir zusammen mit ibi zurück in
das jahr 2007 den baby hat einen zehn
jahre alten block 5 gefunden
wie haltet euch einen kommentar unter
den netten jungs gewünscht wäre ihr
youtube eskaliert heißt ich weiß noch
nicht so ganz mit dem aber nicht so ganz
warm aber wäre jetzt zu hause sitzt und
eine blendende idee habt ihr dieses
format heißen könnte dann schreibst du
einfach in die kommentare gerade stahl
oder ich bin stark ja wieder einmal dass
irgendwo
richtung von allen guten geistern
verlassen alles klar
wir besprechen erstmal detail wohl
irgendwas läuft und springt genau jetzt
mit einer zeit zurück in der er noch
keine produktive baby in die zeit von
bibis blog palace alles klar
so braucht man also jungs vor mir ist
keiner gesagt die leute willkommen zu
meinem ersten block seit langer zeit ich
dachte mir heute einfach mal ich hab
mich auch mal mein kind ist auch mein
ohr was sie hier ist auch eine sekunde
hintergrund alles klar das war genug
wunderschön leute wieder was gelernt
ich hab mit dem kettcar sich mit ersten
minute tut mir leid in paris lockt
einfach vergessen machen und jo leute
ich bin's wieder escape blog tempel
heute dreht sich alles um meine nase
weil du ich bin ja gab mit dem kumpel
der ist gerade kacken welches ins
glaubwürdig ist einfach zu fett isst im
raum schreit und jetzt leute oder wird
sich letztlich spiel ins kraut ist es
mega wie sie selber sagt dahinden
hochgefahren und pc erschienen die
kamera und falls es wirklich leute die
halt auch nicht aufmuckte bloggen sie
redet einfach konstant die ganze zeit so
auch die einzige erklärung ist die
kamera kein schwenkbaren bildschirm
hatte war ich mal vor ihr fühlt euch mit
eurer iphone innen kamera und ihr seht
einfach dass eure fresse nicht mal ganz
drauf ist auf dem fucking bild es ist
einfach nur eure leiste oder wahlweise
auch mal so von unten ich meine dass sie
gut jetzt natürlich helfen ja am anfang
seiner karriere hat jeder große fehler
gemacht ich hab fucking große fehler
gemacht und ich bin froh dass ich mich
so groß dass ich meine alten videos
anschaut das verdankt
werde ich auch nie bitte ob die leute
steht weiter im text bibi hat nach dem
neuen video verunfallte ich würde darum
die fans personen in der ecke ist wie
wir es leider dieser alten videos selber
nicht unkommentiert freigegeben richtig
geil von ihr gewesen das einfach
kommentarlos zu laden hat sie natürlich
nicht gemacht selbstverständlich würde
ich auch nicht machen sondern wird auch
josef zimmer gelegt und dies ist einfach
da gerade wo ihr mich jederzeit bietet
gerade unter mir aber man bemerkt auf
jeden fall schon
sie hat ihr blog ingame abgesteppt wie
hat sich verbessert von voll in die
fresse film in einer guten qualität zu
wir halten die kamera schief in einer
richtig beschissen qualität da sind wir
auch die kunden wie schon in jungen
kindes jahren mit 31 war die gute
glücklich kulturell gebildet wo städter
leute hat manche täter würden euch
erzählen davon fuß kette ausspricht aber
lasse schon den nichts sagen
peter jeder geht und ihr wollt dieses
getötete brot mit tomaten drauf und
olivenöl und knoblauch und zwiebeln
vielleicht auch dann bestellt einfach
rouge et brewster und dabei ist es ganz
wichtig dass ihr das eher nicht rollt
ganz wichtig das machen nur die
italiener und die haben keine ahnung
davon wie man das wort ausspricht
[Musik]
moment mal 14 jahre alt und es geht
schon baby und julian love videos von
vor zehn jahren alter schwede darstellt
meine ganzen theorien auf den kopf
zitiert haben ich und alle andern
youtuber mit dem ich darüber geredet hat
und zwar schon ein paar gedacht dass
julian einfach hundertprozentig schwules
aber dieses video ist zehn jahre alt
angeblich und da gibt's schon lauf
schilder oder in love kommt vielleicht
von debian julian stech zwar for you
tube was wiederum bedeuten würde dass
damit noch kein grund gab eine beziehung
führe zuschauer zufrieden
hier haben wir ein bild von einer baby
in wilder laufbahn von vor zehn jahren
ich sag jetzt einfach gar nicht so
ferner hat jeder zeit nicht ausgesehen
bitte wir als ich vor zehn jahren war
11 wisst ihr wie beschissen ich mit elf
aussah alter also wurde zusammengefasst
können wir sagen dass die zeit damals
doch deutlich besser wartezeit von
gebiet flop palace wo das gewicht auf
deutlich näher an der kamera war waren
die dinge einfach besser wieso war nicht
da ein paar millionen weniger war auch
nicht da definitiv selbst bestände
schöne aber der produkt palast stand
einfach nicht so fünf treffer in einem
video gab damals einfach nicht wenn ich
für diese zeit fehlt
wenn leute weiß ich nicht ob ich lachen
oder weinen soll
lachen weise schön war
oder weil
wie viele reine danke fürs zuschauen so
weit wir euch mal wieder kein ausdruck
ist für mich aber auch immer ganz
gespannt was wir von anfang an war
meistens immer jeden tag eine idee aus
der nase ziehen muss ich mache was mir
gerne mit videos von anzuschauen mehr
kommentar abzugeben ich hoffe jetzt auf
gefallen lassen nach oben dauerten bis 1